[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact in August 2013
Tony Yali was declared dead when his
heart stopped beating for 45 minutes
after heroic efforts failed to revive
the 37 year-old diesel mechanic nurses
invited the family in to see the body
and a bid farewell that's when y'all
ease distraught teenage son Lawrence
told his father dad you're not gonna die
today suddenly he noticed a flicker on
the heart monitor dr. Rajan is here his
cardiologist at Kettering medical center
told ABC news
I thought we'd better make another
effort to revive him incredibly the
effort succeeded and he soon had a
normal heartbeat
Tony was back home in a few days having
no physical side effects from the
experience and then returned to work
doctors think it might have been a viral
infection Tony's wife Melissa said she
Lawrence and the people from their
church who were praying were certain
they witnessed a miracle even the doctor
used the word miracle to describe what
occurred the other interesting fact is
that Tony Yali had absolutely no memory
of the entire ordeal from when he went
to bed on August 4 until he woke up in
the hospital so why is it so many people
claim supernatural visions when they
have a near-death experience stay with
his friends we're going to learn more on
this edition of bible answers why
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 known for 800
God says 804 63 72 97 brings you into
the program and we're not only going out
over hundreds of radio stations as
Sirius XM satellite across the country
and a Facebook if you want to watch the
program you can see what's happening
here in the studio by going to either
the amazing facts Facebook page or the
Doug Batchelor Facebook page and I am
Doug Batchelor my name is John Ross good
evening friends and pass the Duggars we
always do let's start the program with
prayer your father once again we are
grateful for the opportunity to open up
your word and study together and we do
pray that you would be with us here in
the studio as we open the Bible and
study and be with those who are
listening wherever that might be in the
car or at home and we pray Lord that we
would by your grace be able to bring
some clearer understanding to your word
for we ask this in Jesus name Amen
amen well fasted I hear from the program
by talking about one of those near-death
experiences and this one in particular
is rather remarkable where his heart
stopped not just for a few minutes but
for an extended period of time what
about 40 minutes well they say 45
minutes in his wife who is a nurse woke
up in the morning noticed he wasn't
breathing had no heartbeat
she called 9-1-1 they sent paramedics
tried to revive him all the way to the
hospital
worked on him for half an hour at the
hospital and they said you know
eventually you have to just call it you
say there's nothing they
they gave him the adrenaline they did
everything we do on their code cart and
they just said well better let the
family say goodbye and when the Sun came
in he pointed and shouted at his father
dad you can't die today cause he was
just distraught and then there was a
little beep on the monitor and he said
look I saw something there's a minute
later it did it again they said wow what
was that and so they thought there's a
flicker and they went to work on him and
soon they got his heart going again and
they made some things there was no
negative results it's incredible he had
he had no usually there's all kinds of
pain and aches from the chest
compressions and from the drugs and no
heart damage no cholesterol he had no
heart disease 37 woke up and said I feel
fine and so the doctor said this is a
miracle he'd never seen that before but
the thing that was really interesting is
usually hear a story about that someone
about that long and the news is then
gonna say and he went to heaven for half
an hour and came back and he saw
everybody or he went to hell and came
back and wrote a book and did a bunch of
videos and we forget there's so many
people that when they die they don't
have these near-death experiences but
why do so many people have these
experiences now I don't want to discount
that someone may you know the Lord could
speak to him through a dream or vision
God could do that for anyone but I know
people that are getting their theology
about death from somebody's a near-death
experience but science has done a number
of studies where they're shown that when
a person's heart stops beating and their
brain is robbed of oxygen it is
extremely common for them to hallucinate
a few things cause it actually the dying
of brain cells causes hallucinations
they've discovered and when pilots pull
too many G's they can pass out because
it's not enough blood to the brain
it's very common the matter of fact they
studied a thousand cases and these
pilots that pass out
when the pilot is pulling too many G's
at co-pilots in the back and he doesn't
have his pressure suit up and he loses
consciousness and they have euphoria
tunnel vision out of body experiences
dreamless beautiful places I think go
through a lot of them they see old
friends and have conversations and it's
almost identical to people who say well
I
I had an experience now the interesting
thing is around the world when people
have near-death experiences people in
America have a Christian background they
often have a Christian themed near-death
experience they see Jesus and whatever
you know people in India they might see
Krishna and if you go to Thailand they
say oh yeah I nearly died and Buddha
spoke to me and it's like whatever is
already in their brain they hallucinate
with I'm just appealing to our friends
out there when you want to find out what
happens when a person dies please do not
base your theology on somebody's
experience when they die on the
operating table or in a car accident or
whatever you know the the situation
might be because we don't get our
theology from somebody has a dream and
writes a book or says I had this
experience because they all contradict
each other and some people have a
near-death experience and they say I was
in a tunnel and there were two lights
and there's a blue light and this voice
says if you want to be a boy in your
next life you go life you go through
this door and then you go through the
pink door if you want to be a girl and
do people all kinds of crazy dreams so
don't get your theology from someone's
near-death experience and if you want to
know more about it we've got a premium
offer listen up because we haven't
offered this before we've got a magazine
it's a new one that amazing facts
developed and it's dealing with the
subject of what happens when a person
dies it's called the afterlife mystery
and then the subtitle its decoding death
hell and eternal life and as past that
I've mentioned we haven't offered this
for free before but we're doing that
this evening so if you'd like to learn
more about this important subject
especially past that at this time of the
year we're coming up on October 31 of
course Halloween and there's a lot of
discussions about ghosts and death and
what happens when a person dies well
this magazine addresses these from a
biblical perspective what does the Bible
say on the subject it's called the
afterlife mystery and we'll be happy to
send it to anyone who calls and asks the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
that is our resource phone line just
call that number and ask for our free
offer tonight it's called the afterlife
mystery the magazine one more time
that's 800
eight three five six seven four seven
and if you have a Bible question I've
online to the studio is 800 four six
three seven two nine seven and with that
we gonna go to our first caller this
evening we've got Chris listening in
Florida Chris welcome to the program
thank you so much pastor
good evening evening thanks for calling
I just have a question about Bible
translation you know King James Version
from 1611 right right and versus do a
Rams 1602 whatever it was which one is
more accurate and which one we should go
by you said the King James and what was
the other version you mentioned
oh the way the douay-rheims version yeah
that's the Catholic Bible well I would
go with the King James but if it's a
choice between the two because the de
way or the Catholic Bible has a number
of what we would call apocryphal books
that are included that are not in the
traditional Christian or Protestant
they're viewed as suspicious they're
books that are not referenced by any
other Bible author they seem to appear
in history now the Maccabees has some
good historical information but I'm
talking about some of the other
apocryphal books that you find between
the Testaments so I would stick with the
King James Version King James New King
James they come from the Textus Receptus
those would be your I think you're safer
versions but Martin Luther King it's
translated Romans
it's a part of King James Version right
yeah now you don't mean Martin Luther
King he's the preacher you mean Martin
Luther Martin Luther did transit he did
a German translation of Romans the you
know book of Romans that we have in our
English Bibles I think it's based upon
Wickliffe and Tyndale's early
translations and the King James
translators expanded on that but you
know pastor Ross I think we've got a
book that talks about the Bible that
would be happy to send a free coffee to
Chris yeah it's a book called the
ultimate resource it's all about the
Bible and different translations where
they come from well be happy to send
this to anyone who calls and asks again
the books called the ultimate resource
and
number is 883 five six seven four seven
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven I asked for the book the
ultimate resource if you enjoy hearing
solid biblical answers on Bible answers
live you can have those same insights at
your fingertips through the amazing
facts prophecy study Bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and includes the
complete set of amazing facts 27 study
guides plus a Bible numbers and symbols
chart and eight pages of colorful maps
this best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical cyclope 'dick index words of
Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five three eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
538 7275
for life changing Christian resources
visit AF bookstore com we've got bill
listening in Illinois bill welcome to
the program I attached a joke Pastor
John how are you this evening doing
great great um I have a question I
wanted to know I'm reading the King
James Version Bible and I wanted to know
if he can explain Deuteronomy chapter 23
verse 2 yeah it it says there that
someone of illegitimate birth shall not
enter the Assembly of the Lord even to
the tenth generation none of his
descendants shall enter the Assembly of
the Lord you're wondering why would why
would it say that someone who's
illegitimate it's not their fault why
should they not be able to enter the
Assembly of the Lord and even for
generations
well you know I've wondered about that
just to be honest I think the reason
that God did that is he was emphasizing
to the people how important it was to
have the marriage covenant that as soon
as society starts to act like it doesn't
matter
then it sends a message to parents but
the parents decision are a man and a
woman's decision to procreate outside of
marriage has ramifications even for the
children now there's no record you know
there's some pretty Stern ideals that
you find in Deuteronomy then you don't
later see any record of it being
enforced for example it says a Moabite
was not to enter the congregation of the
Lord well Ruth was a Moabite and of
course her grandson great-grandson was
David and he built a temple and then
Jeff's ax who was illegitimate he was a
judge so I think God is sending a signal
here that when they came to the temple
and this may be more specifically pastor
Ross talking about the people who are to
be participating in the sacrifice
because they had some pretty strong
rules regarding the Levites but I have
to take a look at that yeah it's a good
question bill God was saying you know he
felt he felt very strongly about
families parents making that decision to
procreate outside of a family couldn't
have ramifications for the offspring oh
I see all right thank you all right
thanks a lot
next quarter we have is Travis listening
from South Carolina
Travis welcome to the program thank you
appreciate it good evening hi my
question Pastor dog is directed towards
you
I was watching prophecy code a couple of
weeks ago and I heard something that I
had never heard before and you said that
the American Indian also observed a
seven-day week or had a seven-day week
and that the seventh day they called
God's day and I was wondering where I
can learn more about that yeah well it
wasn't all the Indians there's there
were hundreds of tribes maybe thousands
in North America but I worked for about
a year and a half with the Navajo I
think it was actually the Sioux a Sioux
that told me before and I never use the
word Bela Ghana for a white person
before the Bela Ghana came that says we
had a seven-day week because they would
divide up
the month in four parts and it
technically because they did it by the
moon and you got about 28 days in the
lunar cycle four times seven and but
it's it's not exactly 28 but they they
just rounded it out and they would
divide up their month in the sets of
seven now like I said you go down to the
Inca you're gonna find different
calendars and if you talk to the Aztec
but there were American Indian tribes it
had seven-day week so if you want to
know more about it i yeah i just say
search the internet and hopefully you
can find something there okay
appreciate it alright hey thanks a lot
you're welcome thank you uh-huh in six
days God created the heavens and the
earth for thousands of years man has
worshipped God on the seventh day of the
week now each week millions of people
worship on the first day what happened
why did God create a day of rest does it
really matter what day we worship who is
behind this great shift discover the
truth behind God's law and how it was
changed visit Sabbath truth com4
life-changing christian resources visit
AF bookstore calm or call one eight
hundred five three eight seven two seven
five next caller that we have is let's
see we've got let's go to Kelvin in
Thousand Oaks California
Calvin welcome to the program well hello
thank you for taking my call I just had
a question on first John chapter 5 verse
today we're going there alrighty and
your question is okay so in the first it
mentioned something about that there is
a sin that not that does not lead to
death but then in Romans chapter 6 verse
23 he says so the wages of sin is death
and so I was just wanting to understand
that verse a little bit more even though
it says the wages for sin are death we
can be forgiven for most sin the Bible
says there is one sin this blasphemy
against the Holy Spirit for which there
is no forgiveness if we grieve away the
Holy Spirit we lose the capacity to
repent and then there's no forgiveness
and this is a tough first but I think
most people are thinking and scholars
that John
is referencing here the unpardonable sin
when a person commits the unpardonable
sin he said you don't even need to pray
about it you know that person there's
some people that have just totally
rejected the Lord you know it's like the
Pharaoh of Egypt he just hardened his
heart and grieved away the Holy Spirit
King Saul God would not speak to him
anymore and they ended up killing
himself Jesus told Judas it would be
better that that man was not born
because he he finally you know even
though Jesus went to wash his feet he
walked out and betrayed Christ a person
can get to the point where they reached
that point of no return
most people listening right now have not
done that because you usually have no
appetite for spiritual things at that
point speaking of I think it's talking
about the unpardonable sin and I was
just going to say that if you'd like I
have a book I can send you and it's
called you know what is the unpardonable
sin and I think it references this verse
in there if you'd like a free copy
all right thanks you're Col Calvin the
number to call is 883 five six seven
four seven that is the resource phone
line and asked for the book what is the
unpardonable sin again that's 800 this
for anyone eight three five six seven
four seven and ask for the book called
what is the unpardonable sin our next
call of the behalf is Ruth am listening
from Michigan Ruth Ann welcome to the
program
oh thanks this is like the second time I
called in a couple of years well thanks
for calling you know I read you know I'm
always I read the Bible I try to read it
like about an hour at night that's one
of the best time for me to read the
Bible but I keep running across seven
and seventy could you tell me what that
means you know I saw your question the
screeners put it up here and I typed in
the number seven into my computerized
Bible and the number seven appears 461
times in the Bible so you are right it
is yeah it is the most commonly repeated
number in the Bible of course you find
it in Genesis God makes the world and
seven days right and then the number
seven appears all the way through
revelation where
the last book in the Bible has got seven
churches seven trumpets seven plagues
seven thunder 7i seven horns that's just
the beginning seven seals yeah a lot of
the seven there were seven heads on the
beast and seven plagues okay we're gonna
try and up each other's here I guess
more seventh out of Revelation it's it's
a number that represents a complete
cycle it's God's like perfect cycle you
get the week seven days God seems to
always do things in a complete cycle of
seven and even said with forgiveness you
forgive seventy times seven in that de
perak Bowl in Matthew 18
yeah and 70 you know it's it's it's ten
times seven the other numbers that
appear frequently you're gonna run into
our twelve ten three and I think forty
yeah like 40 a generation a lot of
forties in the Bible that represents a
generation twelve represents the church
you know what I think if you look at our
we've got a website called Bible
Universe and if you go there we've
actually got a section a tab that says
numbers in the Bible there's a whole
study on numbers in the Bible and what
they mean take a look at Bible universe
and you'll find that there thank you
very much
all right thanks Ruthie I appreciate
your call you too bye next call that we
have is we've got Michael listening in
Miami Florida Michael welcome to the
program hello okay here we load and
clear how are you doing all right great
so yeah I suppose look is a bit of a
process to my question I sort of been in
this place
lately in my spirituality I guess gonna
say the where I'm not entirely certain
of how much of my faith because I
basically grow from the church I'm not
sure how much my faith is based on like
true personal conviction as opposed to
being based on just living of I guess
where you can say like off of what
people taught me to live like you know
just claiming to believe in something
just because I was taught to believe it
and I suppose off of that basis there's
really like a whole litany of questions
that I could ask but the one that's been
on my mind lately because of my
of why I'm in school I'm a college
student a senior that is and I wanted to
ask about Christians and and movies
because I'm a I'm a visual effects
student and my the career path I I wish
I can see developing for myself is
really toward the line of of cinematic
visual effects and I've always also had
like a great interest in like you know
fiction and and it will I'll just be
upfront with it like the comic book type
movies and stuff like that um I know
this usually there's a version I think
in certain Christmas circles about like
the violence and all the other stuff
that's in there but I'm always like
sometimes I'm wondering there's just
that a movie depicts violence or depicts
certain things that makes it wrong or
bad because I mean like in a story
there's you know I don't I'm sure there
should be from a version to depicting
things like violence or because that
that's um a part of reality I suppose at
least for us now and yeah you know I
suppose I could approach this question
many different ways but I'm just curious
as to what your take is on on movies and
and that sort of line works yeah well
you've asked some good questions let me
just divvy up your question if I can
first of all on the technical side
there's no question that God can
communicate through the medium of film
or digital or movies we've actually got
a motion graphic employee here at
amazing facts and we created a recent
DVD kingdoms in time and yeah we use
motion graphics and I've got a TV but
most of the TV programming I wouldn't
recommend but a TV like a book most
books are not good but there are some
good books the Bible is a book it's a
medium of communication most of what
you'll hear on the radio is probably
nonsense but you can hear Christian
radio the movie industry that technology
can be used to communicate truth most of
what's out there is not good I don't go
to movies because for one thing I don't
think it's a good witness they're
expensive and and most of what you would
see there it's not good
and if there is something good it
usually
comes out a little later and a lot
cheaper format the heart of your
question there's several important
issues bottom line is the Bible says
whatever things are pure noble just
lovely of good report you have to apply
that test there in Philippians to say
you know is what I'm creating looking at
is it something that Jesus will bless is
it good
you know just apply that it's not
because of you know some church
traditions are great but you want to
really back it up with a biblical
principle and I think holiness would be
the principle you would apply to
whatever you do hey thank you Michael
we're gonna try and squeeze in one more
call before our mid program break pastor
oz can we do it yes we've got let's go
to Sarah in Sacramento Sarah welcome to
the program hi thanks for taking my call
yeah and your question my my question is
so I know that you can be like 100%
filled with God but I know that he also
says that it's not good for a man to be
alone and so he created Eve for Adam
does that mean like if you don't get
married are you always kind of like
missing something to God see that there
was something missing and so he created
Eve or well you know certainly there was
something missing if God wanted them to
procreate because that only happens
through a partnership but there are a
lot of great people that were spirit
filled incomplete through the Bible that
were not married in a going from Daniel
to the Apostle Paul to Jesus you know in
the normal order of things for a family
it's best rounded out with the father
and the mother I think any father who's
missing a mother will say you know this
is difficult to raise children or vice
versa a woman without the husband around
my mom largely raised my brother and I
without my dad's help at least his
presence yeah it's so that's part of
God's perfect plan but I don't know that
you know when we have the Lord he fills
whatever vacuum there might be missing
in a relationship that doesn't mean yeah
you know obviously God creates people
with a desire for that kind of
companionship right but it doesn't mean
they can't be complete without it right
keep in mind in heaven jesus said don't
either Mary nor given
marriage and they're gonna feel a
hundred percent fulfilled right okay
great thank you all right hey thanks so
much you know pastor Russ I don't know
if we'd be able to get in another call
maybe we could mention our free offer
again that we're making available
tonight yes it's the magazine called the
afterlife mystery dealing with the
subject of death hell and eternal life
from a biblical perspective and we'll be
happy to send this to anyone it's free
the number to call is 883 five six seven
four seven and ask for the magazine on
called the afterlife mystery yeah now
we're not going away we're coming back
with more Bible questions the best is
yet to come just give us a call 800 for
6 372 97 with your Bible questions we
also like to remind people if you go to
the amazing facts website it's just so
easy it's that word amazing facts dot
o-r-g you'll find it if you do amazing
facts comm if you go to might even find
it amazing facts dot info you'll lots of
information coming right back
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
we know we're here but we're not here
for very long so the most important
thing would be if we could learn during
this life how to live forever this is
the central focus of amazing facts I
think it's very important for us to
build churches but if the churches lose
the message of salvation they just
become buildings and shells I think it's
important to have a medical ministry and
build hospitals but if they separate
that from the message of salvation you
just prolong a sinners life for a little
while that's why for years amazing facts
has made it our focus to present the
saving truth that sets people free and
Friends we want to thank you for your
support in your gifts we'll do our very
best to convert those resources into the
currency of heaven may God bless you and
keep amazing facts in your prayers deep
within the pages of the Bible stories of
great heroes heroes of great deeds great
love and great sacrifice but behind them
is another hero hidden in plain sight
amid the shadows
he was there from the beginning
and he'll be there until the end
discover the golden thread of a savior
woven throughout the entire bible
tapestry shadows of light seeing Jesus
in all the Bible get your copy today by
calling 855-578-6767 for 7 now let's
join pastors doug batchelor and john
ross for more Bible answers live welcome
back listening friends to Bible answers
live and if you have a Bible question
give us a call 800 God says 800 4 6 3 7
2 97 brings your Bible question to our
studio here on the outskirts of
Sacramento streaming around the world
and bouncing off of satellites you can
give us a call with your Bible questions
and my name is Doug Batchelor my name is
John Ross and next hole of that we have
is Kelly
listening in Utah Kelly welcome to the
program hello thanks for taking my call
you I just want to know how I can help
friend better understand the fear of God
she says that when she hears believers
describes themselves as god-fearing she
wonders why they should worship the same
being they care so much
well would you want to worship someone
who is not awesome when when you think
about how tremendous and big you know
people kind of overuse certain words you
everything's awesome now they say if
french fries are awesome and they've
kind of taken away the the impact of the
words but God is such a powerful
omnipresent omnipotent being that you
know he's made the heavens of heavens
and to think that you know you shouldn't
tremble if that thought but you can love
him and that's the the dichotomy is God
says you can come to him I love you more
than a parent loves their child you know
children might feel some fear of their
their father's strength and his
discipline but still love them and crawl
up into their lap Jesus uses that word
he says when you pray say our Father
it's that kind of a love relationship
that sort of as a paradox where you've
got the awesomeness of God when prophets
and others saw God face-to-face they
trembled just the majesty of it all the
glory the brightness but at the same
time they continued to worship him and
love him yeah yes yeah that's a
challenge I mean I don't know is if
she's just being blinded by being an
unbeliever that she is my understanding
well does she believe that if they're
lost that people go to hell and burn
forever and ever because some people
it's not just that they fear God they
fear he's cruel yes she she says that
he's cooled it like why if if God knows
what's best and for innocent children to
be abused why does he all these things
to happen like that right
you know what would be really good is if
you could either send her the link to or
send her the DVD called cosmic conflict
it explains why is there evil in the
world if God is good and he's loving
he's powerful why does he allow innocent
people to suffer it's a DVD that you can
also see it online called cosmic
conflict it explains this battle between
good and evil that God is loving but
there's an evil fiend roaming through
the universe get rampaging around our
planet and once she understands that
every good and perfect gift comes from
God that God is not willing that any
should perish that Jesus in God our love
yeah I think it might change her her
attitude so I'd really recommend that ya
cosmic long conflict it's great DVD and
I think pass that I go might be
available in you to be somebody just
types it in they might be able to see it
their journey back through time to the
center of the universe discover how a
perfect angel that transformed into
Satan the arch villain the birth of evil
a rebellion in heaven
amuse me that moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation
discover God's amazing plan to save his
children this is a story that involves
every life on earth every life
the cosmic conflict if God is good if
God is all-powerful if God is love then
what went wrong
next quality we have is William
listening from looks like Pineville
Louisiana yes what do you welcome to the
program alright thank you sir
I have a question could you well
actually could you explain to me
revelation 4 verse 8 alright I master
Ross is our revelation our resident
scholar you want to take a stab at that
well let me read it first revelation 4
verse 8 it says speaking about God's
throne in heaven the four living
creatures each having six wings they
were full of eyes around them within and
they did not rest day or night saying
holy holy holy Lord God Almighty who was
who is and who is to come so you're
wondering who are these four living
creatures yes yes
well you know you read on a little bit
it describes these four living creatures
in a little more detail it says the
first is likened unto a lion he is the
face of a lion the second has a face of
an ox the third has a face of a man and
the fourth has the face of a flying
eagle now remember Revelation is a
symbolic book and the significance to
the symbols that's used in the book of
Revelation it is describing God's throne
it's glorious
and these four living creatures
otherwise sometimes referred to as
Seraphim or cherubim you remember the
Ark of the Covenant that was in the
temple had two angels over the mercy
seat the mercy seat is a symbol of God's
throne
but these four living creatures they
represent something and some have seen
it perhaps the illustration of the
different phases of Christ's ministry
you have the line is often associated
with royalty or kingship and symbolizes
Jesus before the Incarnation you have an
ox which is
a animal of burden bears burden its
sacrificial animal and some people see
when Jesus came to the earth he came to
bear our sins and died sacrifice then
you have the man and the man would
represent Jesus our high priest now
ministering for us in a heavenly
sanctuary an eagle often represents
kingship and speed and power and folks
seeing that when Jesus comes again he
comes as king of kings and Lord of lords
so in these four living creatures they
see four phases of Christ's ministry but
it's part of the throne room part of
God's throne they're in heaven
okay so they're symbolically correct yes
they symbolic but it doesn't mean to say
that they they aren't these literal for
living angels or creatures around God's
throne okay I appreciate it
all right hey thank you so much
appreciate your call William they pull
everybody Zane listening in Colton
California Zane welcome to the program
hey I had a question about I forget what
part it isn't in but before Babylon fell
without bells house and everything the
writing on the wall was a mini mini I
think it's many many many Tekel upharsin
and my question is in fact a language
you know like was a Hebrew or something
like that is that the babbling didn't
understand it or is it like a language
we don't know at all well that's a good
question
Daniel was able to read it and evidently
it it is parts of words in the Persian
or Chaldean language it may have even
been a mixture of that and Aramaic but
it was one of the Semitic languages but
the arrangement of the words left them
wondering like the last word you Farson
and it says your kingdom is given to the
Medes and the Persians well that that's
can be drawn from that word you Farson
so these were words but they're just
arranged like Wayne Wade wanting
Persians you know and so it's like it
was an utterance that didn't a person
didn't know what does it mean and so
each one of the words daniel says he
gives the interpretation you are weighed
in the balances and found wanting
Peres your kingdom is divided and given
to them
means in the Persians and so he tells
you know what the meaning meaning tickle
you farsan means now this part of Daniel
was written in Aramaic and the words
actually in Aramaic have a meaning so
the word mana literally means to number
or to count and same with tickle it's
got a specific meaning so even though
the word had a meaning the question was
well what does this really mean what is
it trying to say and that's we Daniel
explained it and was actually able to
add to it and explain your kingdom is
taken away and given to the Medes and
the Persians now obviously not all of
that is containing the one word but
that's what it meant mm-hmm yeah he
needed to decipher what the these code
words were but they were from real
languages okay thanks a lot
all right thanks appreciate your call
and that opens up another line if you
have a Bible question we still have 16
minutes to go give us a call 800 for six
three seven two 97 next one of it we
have is it now listening from Grand
Ledge Michigan and welcome to the
program good evening pastors evening
thank you for taking my phone calls now
the question that I have is Luke 831
okay you want us to read that and then
we'll talk about what it means I would
yes all right I'm going there right now
it says in Luke 831 I'm just getting
there here we go and they begged him
that he would not command them to go out
into the abyss this is when Jesus
delivers the the man who's called a
demoniac he was filled with demons and
Christ asks the demons what is your name
and they say Legion and they the demons
begged Jesus he would not command them
to go out into the word abyss there it's
a translated same word you find in
Revelation 24 it's abussos and it means
well the abyss the emptiness the
nothingness use this bottomless pit in
Revelation so you wonder it'd be like a
prison house for a demon
well in a sense because the devil is a
workaholic and if you give him nothing
to do the Bible where's that verse
pastor Ross it says in everlasting
chains that Satan's
angels are reserved in everlasting
chains of darkness at either Jude or
Peter or both second Peter I forget ya
these demons if they have nobody but
possess Satan and his angels were cast
to the earth you find that in Revelation
12 and if they have no one to possess
the animal or human then they're bound
by circumstances and so with that being
with that being said then wouldn't it
have been better for Jesus to have sent
them into the abyss instead of into the
blind because they weren't subject to
death all they did was more probable go
into a bunch of water and then come back
up again so I don't understand why Jesus
did that I'll answer that but pastor oz
was gonna read a verse in them yeah just
those two verses you refer to about
change of Darkness it's referred to
twice second Peter chapter 2 verse 4 and
then also Jude chapter 6 speaking about
the fallen angels talks about them being
reserved in Chains under darkness until
the Judgment Day
all right Edna so the big question is
why would Jesus answer the prayer of
demons and let them go into the pigs
where they caused all kinds of havoc
that is a great question it's one of the
only times in the Bible Jesus is
connected with a letting anything die
what happened is when the demons and
they figure there were at least 2,000
demons because in Matthew it says there
were two thousand swine when they filled
the pigs and they went berserk and all
ran off a steep place and crashed down
the cliff and and the drown the Sea of
Galilee is not that big you know you can
see across it and it's surrounded by
Jewish cities and if all of a sudden you
have 2,000 bloated pig carcasses
floating in a Jewish Lake that's what
you call a toxic spill for for Jews
because pigs are unclean and everybody
was wondering what was it that made the
whole sea of galilee unclean with all
these dead pigs and everybody heard the
story of how Jesus set that man free so
the devil's thought oh we're gonna make
it where the locals asked Jesus to leave
which they did but they didn't realize
it was going to back
fire and more people heard about the
miracle it's an all three Matthew Mark
Luke all talk about this miracle of the
demoniac being saved
that's why Jesus let it happen and I
also think there's a spiritual lesson
for us the Bible says pigs are unclean
and devils are unclean so he took the
unclean devils and he put him with the
unclean pigs and they were raising those
pigs not for pets but for food his Bible
says they're not good food so he was
able to kill several birds with one
stone or pigs with one stone so anyway
yeah that's that's a quick answer
thanks so much having a great question
you're listening to Bible answers live
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific Time call us at
one eight hundred seven all God's plan
for our world and solutions for your
life's challenges
beautifully redesigned amazing facts 27
Bible study guides provide encouraging
Bible based answers to questions on
healthier relationships when Jesus will
return and much more refer to watch
while you read our brand new prophecy
encounters DVD series makes the perfect
companion set order your study guides
and DVDs today by visiting AAF bookstore
calm or by calling 858 seven two seven
five four life-changing Christian
resources visit AF bookstore calm next
one other behave is Bobby listening from
looks like Virginia Bobby welcome to the
program hey y'all going today we're
doing good and your question I just have
a question because this man on Kent
Hovind he uh has a lot of Bibles that he
was explaining that before you can focus
a Bible you had to change ten percent of
the wording or ten percent of the verses
or take ten percent of the books out of
the Bible before you can get one
published I then they come back around
he gave all the verses and I looked them
up in the
bible that i thought it was a good bible
because i just got saved in 2013
yeah they're saying that there's some
verses missing from the bible
yes sir alright let me let me explain
see a e-z Bible it's got in there Samuel
1 chapter 21 verse 19 I can't remember
exactly how it says but it says the
Kings killed Goliath which I know better
than that
I didn't realize that I looked it up in
my Bible too haven't got that far in the
Pape what I was reading
yeah well that the translation of the
Bible that you're talking about that I
think it's a century version you know
that's not a good translation if you
stick with the King James translation or
the New King James translation there's
nothing missing from the Bible there are
some there are some independent
characters anybody can print a Bible now
what I mean by that is anyone can claim
I could go out and take a Bible and do
whatever I want and call it The Bachelor
Bible and it's America you can print it
it doesn't mean it's accurate if you
want a good Bible that is sticking with
the original manuscripts then if you use
King James New King James new American
Standard even the new English version
you'll have they're all the same they've
all got the same verses there's no
missing verses yeah you're safe doing
that you get into some of the paraphrase
Bibles and there they go out on a limb
and they say well there was his rare
manuscript and had an extra verse and
they really the verse doesn't appear at
any trustworthy manuscripts explain it
from the Bible he says God says do not
add to or take away from my word
and that's that's what people are doing
because of money you're right there are
people who are adding to and taking away
from his word and says in both
Deuteronomy proverbs and in Revelation
that is serious business
matter of fact revelation says God's
gonna add curses to people that delete
from his word you know Bobby we do have
a book called the ultimate resource I
think you'll really enjoy it it talks
about different translations where they
come from
what a good reliable translations we'll
be happy to send that to you all you
left to do is call and ask for it the
number to call is 883 five six seven
four seven and asked for the book called
the ultimate resource that number again
is 883 five six seven four seven next
caller that we have is Abraham listening
in LA
Abraham welcome to the program Abraham
you might have your phone muted you
there can you hear me
Abraham hello yes your question hey hey
there pastor I just had a quick question
about Deuteronomy chapter 14 starting in
verse 32 and you want me to read that
for everybody yes it says you shall
truly tithe all the increase of your
grain that the field produces year by
year and you shall eat before the Lord
your God in the place where he chooses
to make his name abide and the tithes of
your grain and your new wine and your
oil the firstborn of your herds and your
flocks that you may learn to fear the
Lord God always is that the partner oh
it's not that yeah it's the first part
and then I think a few more verses first
24 it says and if the journey is too
long for you and you're not able to
carry the tithe or if the place where
the Lord God chooses to put his name too
far from you where the Lord God has
blessed you then you shall exchange it
for money and take the money in your
hand and go to the place where the Lord
your God chooses and you'll spend that
money for whatever your heart desires
for oxen sheep wine or similar drink or
whatever your heart desires and they're
usually before the Lord your God and
you'll rejoice you and your household
that's a part yes I wanted to understand
that part there ya know were you
wondering about the part where it says
you can buy wine or similar drink no no
this is the part about you know using
the tie for something else oh okay yeah
yeah yeah because there's some people
asked about the wine part and I thank
God is it okay to drink strong drink
some version is called that strong drink
it doesn't say that so you're asking
about how can you take the tide they had
this is a separate tie that was for the
annual feasts this was not the regular
tithe they were to take some of that
and use it to give to the poor or when
they went to the feast to worship the
Lord they could rather than carry
sacrifices with them they could convert
it to money and he said when you get
there you can buy the ox of the donkey
ox or the sheep or whatever it is that
you're gonna offer they'd offer there
and they'd be able to eat some of the
sacrifice the people used to get to eat
some of their own sacrifice that they
bring to the Lord okay and so this is
not referencing that 10% yeah this is
this is a additional tithe I think that
relates to the feasts the annual feasts
okay
okay understood got it thank you
alrighty thanks so much appreciate your
question next caller that we have is
Daniel listening in Michigan Daniel
welcome to the program oh good evening
sir
evening I just have one thing I disagree
with on the on the Bible I don't
necessarily disagree with it I've never
really totally comprehended it for years
I've heard that we're only supposed to
eat fruits greens and vegetables
according to the Bible and of course he
used to use mullet for bread years ago
which is different than a week that as
gluten and all that but you know people
thought that animals had a soul they
wouldn't be so inclined to shoot them
and eat them basically my question is is
whether they have a soul I know they're
spiritual but do they have a soul let me
get to the point this way if there is a
God which I like to believe there is and
he has not brought us this far to let us
down now you got to ask yourself a
question if we all become civilized the
best we can possibly be in God's eyes
and let's say that happens and we asked
ourselves why'd it takes so many
thousands of years for human beings to
get along with one another and I think
the answer would be that we were so
sadistic and abusive Daniel you need to
put this in a question we're running out
of time yeah well in other words if
there is a higher power if we look back
in God has brought us this part was if I
let us down now and we look back and say
well ok where symbolizes we can possibly
be in God's eyes we would look back into
a light takes so many years thousands of
years people to get along I think the
answer would be that we couldn't
understand our animals the way we should
have and by doing so we would have
understand human nature much more all
right so now you I did hear a question
in there about whether an animal has a
soul and I think you're saying that if
if people are civilized and why are we
butchering so many animals and and it
seems like not to mention people butcher
each other in war my short answer would
be that of course is not God's will if
you ever want to know what in God I can
promise you does exist if you want to
know what did God intend the very
beginning of the Bible God made
everything good good very good people
were not killing the animals Adam and
Eve they named the animals they were
companions they were they loved them and
even not only didn't God intend man to
live forever the animals were not gonna
die they were gonna live forever and the
Bible tells us in heaven the wolf will
lay down with the the lamb the ox and
the lion and the fatling meaning the
calf they'll all play together with a
child nothing's gonna hurt in heaven I
think that's Isaiah chapter 11 you're on
the right track Daniel that you know God
is saddened by the wickedness in the
world the devil brought all kinds of
pain to the creation and God has
developed a plan through the sacrifice
of his son to save the world from sin
and to restore the world to its original
identic duty I think I sense in your
question just the frustration with why
there's the death and the pain and so
many animals suffering and here we're
supposed to be a civilized society I for
one am a vegetarian I think pastor Ross
is a vegetarian so we're not killing the
animals in any way and we thank you for
your question
we get one more in pastor Ross I know a
quick one we got Robert from Walla Walla
Washington Robert thanks for your
patience you're on the air
all right there hi Robert we've got just
60 seconds can we do it hopefully so
I've been waiting patiently I was
wanting to know why arts in John 5:19
did God the Father died in John 5:19
well God the Father did not die there's
I don't see anything in the Bible that
says the father died you're talking
about the verse where it says most
assuredly the son can do nothing of
himself but what he sees the father do
for whatever he does the son does he
wondering does that mean then because
Jesus died the father must have died I
would simply say that another
denomination saying yeah no I don't
believe that I don't believe that this
verse is telling us that God the Father
died the father no doubt was
brokenhearted through the death of the
son but Jesus isn't referring to that
when he's answering this question and if
someone's teaching that unfortunately
they're off course
hey listening friend I apologize Robert
give us another chance give it a another
call for another night we're running out
of time for tonight's questions want to
remind everybody that you'll notice we
dedicate our time to answering questions
if you're blessed if you're edified by
this program join us you can go online
to amazing facts and keep us on the air
god bless
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
terror attacks natural disasters
political instability and global
economic meltdown these are the images
people generally associate with the
tribulation and the day of the Lord but
did you know the Bible speaks about
another day of the Lord just before the
great Judgment Day
amazingly imprinted on the very fabric
of time itself is a 24-hour period
called the Sabbath that was meant to
forever be a time of restoration for
every human being a day the entire world
is largely forgotten you'll be surprised
to learn how this special day of the
Lord
factors into last day prophecies such as
the mark of the beast the seal of God
and the great final tribulation it's all
contained in this new eye-opening DVD
series called the last day of prophecy
to order call 800 538 7 to 75 or visit
AF bookstore com
what if you could know the future what
would you do what would you change to
see the future you must understand the
past Alexander the Great becomes king
when he's only 18 but he's a military
prodigy a hundred and fifty years in
advance Cyrus had been named wrong was
violent they were ruthless they were
determined the Gospel writers seek his
death as a fulfillment of salvation this
intriguing documentary hosted by Pastor
Doug Batchelor explores the most
striking bible prophecies that have been
dramatically fulfilled throughout
history kingdoms in time get your copy
today available now on DVD blu-ray or
USB for more information visit kingdoms
in time.com
for over 50 years amazing
you